[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look at the ladies y'all are working it
at night let me tell ya how's it looks
like you guys are ready to have some fun
I imagine it's gonna be what did you
guys feel like coming to the Emmys that
I mean my gosh the number of nominations
did you guys ever expect this when you
read the first strip too big a little
ice like gosh no I mean this this
journey has been I mean we hoped we
thought it would be good but we didn't
think I would connect in this way yeah
it's been incredible the audience
responds and they made it what it was I
mean people watched every meet got
excited watch with their friends and
we're just so thankful to everybody out
there who made it it hit that it is you
know I talked to here director up here
and I asked him I said everybody wants
to know is there gonna be a season
number two and he said you have to ask
the girls yes he did these if you cut
out the girls so I'm asking the girls is
there gonna be a season number two we're
thinking about I mean we're talking
about it that's a good answer yes bring
a party or working together so much fun
making it obviously
performances in terms of what we were
asked to do was extraordinary too
because seven hours in each storyline is
so interesting and complicated so when
do you get that right but it kind of
feels wildly unfair that we get to work
together have all this fun and then get
to come to a fun party like that sounds
true right there's not to put the
pressure on but on a scale to like one
to ten like how likely is it to happen
I'm just doing this for our viewers who
love you guys so much you know not
rushing things have to happen everybody
has to be free that you know everything
scripts have you great we want we don't
want to like it okay version every what
did you like a great version of it so we
just want it to be great for the people
because who wants to watch again not
good version everyone all the pieces
fall into place then it'll happen thank
you I'm doing it just purely for the
viewers like myself
and I love the characters like we love
the characters that is just so
gratifying
[Music]
you